spirit we break it right now
in the name of jesus every antichrist
spirit we break it right now
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
are being dispatched they're coming here
in the name of jesus
in south america they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
victory victory victory in the quarters
of heaven
victory victory victory victory victory
victory
[Laughter]
are being released right now angels are
being dispatched they're coming here
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
[Music]
[Music]
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike until
you have victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be
that we would strike the ground for you
will give us victory god
i hear a sound of abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of shouting and singing i
hear a sound of victory
we stop and we override the will of man
for the will of god
we override the will of man for the will
of god
all right welcome everybody we have
ourselves a debate at the top of the
hour
there were in theory there could be two
debates in the georgia senate because
there are two
runoffs uh kelly leffler versus
raphael warnock is one race the other is
david perdue versus
john ossoff now john ossoff is
reportedly earlier today he just went up
there
opposite an empty podium because
um david perdue is refusing to debate
and if you're wondering
why david perdue is refusing to debate
you
need only watch this video this is why
david perdue
will not do any more debates well
perhaps
senator perdue would have been able to
respond properly to the kovid 19
pandemic
if you hadn't been fending off multiple
federal investigations for insider
trading
it's not just that you're a crook
senator
it's that you're attacking the health of
the people that you represent
you did say covid19 was no deadlier than
the flu
you did say there would be no
significant uptick in cases
all the while you were looking after
your own assets and your own portfolio
and you did vote four times to end
protections for pre-existing conditions
four times and the legislation that you
tout the protect act
it includes loopholes that specifically
allow
insurance companies right to deny
policies
to georgians with pre-existing
conditions can you look down the camera
and tell the people of this state
why you voted four times to allow
insurance companies
to deny us health coverage because we
may suffer from diabetes
i actually had to call atlanta police
and report a murder when i saw this it
was gruesome
so anyway that was the last debate and
david perdue refused to participate in
subsequent debates
um during the lead up to november 3rd
and then so far is not willing to appear
in any more in any any more debates
with jon ossoff so that we will not be
having today
it is kelly leffler versus rafael
warnock
at the top of the hour okay um
very good then i have so
many different remixes and things for
you guys oh
landon says he sent me the latest one
okay let me get right to that so i had
the old version
here let me get the new version so
yesterday i played
a voicemail from violent angry trumpist
jimmy from philly
and at the end of it he says f your
cappuccino just as a sort of final salvo
on the way out
and landon echeverio as you can see here
did a beautiful remix of it let's listen
to it together my friends
i've not listened to this let's listen
to it together
and and see what it what it's about
david jimmy from philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired
and listen to your [ __ ] about
unhinged trump supporters and this and
that
make yourself full of [ __ ] i i got
my hat's off to you you can't you you
you can't withstand it david you got my
information [ __ ]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
dark
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
all right so we you know we'll have the
the whole track uh at some point
forthcoming
let me go through everything else that i
have for you guys
um rudy giuliani is positive for the
virus he has tested positive and
reportedly is already hospitalized
now my real take on this is
wait a second where is it my real take
on this
listen my real take on this is obviously
he has the virus he's been flying around
every day with no mask at these hearings
with a hundred two hundred people of
course it's shocking that he didn't
already get it now
just as a as a sort of fake conspiracy
i tweeted earlier doesn't anyone
find it a little suspicious that just as
rudy was traveling all over the country
ready to expose affidavits that would
overturn the election
he gets coveted and now has to stop
exposing the fraud too convenient
this is me kidding around obviously like
he was not ready to
overturn anything but i guess this got
picked up by some trending like see how
it's trending here
that rudy has covered so a whole bunch
of people responded and they agree
like look yeah it is a bit of a stretch
glap he's not sick he's just hiding
um what are other ones here
uh people just believing that that this
was for real
i wonder if trump sidelined him because
of all the losing
i absolutely agree they're out of tricks
and so i had to go back in and say holy
[ __ ] i can't believe i have to add this
but my post is satire you lunatics
so i thought that this was obviously so
stupid
that nobody would believe i was being
real but
a bunch of people did and i had to go
back in and issue a very very strong
disclaimer
um you know that i'm not a lunatic
conspiracy theorist so we've got that
um oh okay i have do you guys want to do
a couple of other remixes hot off the
presses
or um oh i even got an
anti-semitic reply to my conspiracy yeah
it's crazy it attracted all of the wrong
people
uh it's it's completely nuts i i have a
couple new songs i'll play them for you
guys momentarily
i will be doing new member thank yous i
will be doing um
i will be doing twitch sub thank yous
and and all of that stuff
a few super chats puppet says thank you
so much to michael schweigart says
blessed be
david if democrats take the senate and
try to make puerto rico a state would it
likely be met with a filibuster
i'm not even getting ahead of myself i'm
doing it
step by step the next step is let's see
if democrats can take the senate
okay so that's the the super chats that
we have
um and if you're just joining us this is
a live debate does anybody know actually
how long it's scheduled to be
um because i've got a um i've got a
lobster
lobster soup with scratch made stock uh
that i've gotta
finish up today and i wanna know is this
an hour debate is it a 90 minute do we
have any idea i couldn't find any
information about it
um it is not a bisque it is not a bisque
no nobody knows
all right well we'll see what it is
could be an hour could be it could be
longer
um not really sure
uh it's a brisk bisque absolutely
absolutely uh jordan peterson would be
proud of my my lobster stock yeah for
sure
all right well anyway uh unclear we've
got a debate at the top of the hour
so a couple of other memetic elements
for you guys one of the big memes going
around is this massive dumps thing the
origins of it are right here
happened if you watched the election i
was called by the biggest people
saying congratulations political people
congratulations sir you just won the
election
it was 10 o'clock and you looked at the
numbers and i'm sure you felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps so that oh you have to
have maria adjusting her glasses that's
a key moment let me play that
uh in michigan there it is that's how i
we have huge
massive dumps okay uh so anyway
we have a bunch of really cool this is
one of the best things we've ever had
okay i want everybody right now if
you're not paying attention pay very
close attention
this is from office akimov
okay check out what office akimov did
with this this is i've
never seen anything like it this was
created in just a few days
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it check this out
[Music]
this is life-changing
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led
[Music]
listen guys you can right-wing satire is
stephen crowder dresses like a girl and
thinks it's funny
okay and look at look at the quality of
what we have here you turn the faucet on
in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water
rushes out to sea because people are
flushing toilets
ten times as opposed to once
dumps
[Music]
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody
massive dumps cost them the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here it's just beyond parody
massive dumps cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
okay anyway so this is just an
unbelievable level of skill and
and talent that is unbelievable so
that's that's one of the
parity elements so we got that i played
that for you one other one that's pretty
good i've slipped up the other day and
referred to the award-winning bonus show
as the boner show here is that
let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy so that was also turned into
something unbelievable
[Music]
oh boy let's remind you that we by the
way
the censored microphone it's just all
perfect
oh boy
oh boy let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy so that's absolute genius and
then we also have this is just the final
mimetic element
by the way if you're just joining us
everything's fine we have a debate
scheduled for 10 minutes from now and
we're going to
we're going to get to it so everybody
relax we're just going through some
memes before we get going
the rudy farting has taken over the
world that's just here's a reminder of
that
of order the answer that i gave you is
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you okay so now
that the fart has been turned into a
beat this is by our friend jethro
bradley
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
[Music]
so that's genius and we actually played
trump out yesterday if you were with us
for yesterday's event this is me playing
trump out with that get out and vote
get out and vote all right we'll play
our own music though
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
look at the timing on this
[Music]
there it is oh my god
[Music]
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
[Music]
why don't you look at the registered
voters on there how many registered
voters are on there
again yeah so anyway all right that's
all the memes i have for today
and really i mean just quality quality
stuff at this point um
really really wild so i appreciate
everybody who was here yesterday and um
i think so here here's a new memetic
element it would be great to get so that
just it happened to time out
there's probably a dozen people now the
debate starts in five minutes guys relax
everybody relax
there's probably now enough of people in
the audience who can put this stuff
together
taking one of these songs either you
know it could be rude boy by jethro
bradley
or any of these different songs that
we've been playing and
actually putting it together with trump
dancing
and maybe even trump's dancing and
that's superimposed onto something else
that's funny
i think there's a real chance here for
an absolutely perfect
perfect perfect uh mimetic video so all
right very good let me get back to the
things that matter
um nicole liberty has just basically
epitomized the last year in the david
pakman show
if your coupon code isn't illegal
these remixes have to be i feel the
exact same way nicole i appreciate that
i want to thank waxwell for just
donating
25 subscriptions over on twitch
and let's get the party started from the
standpoint of numbers we are at zero
we have had a total of 30 new twitch
subs just while we've been playing
essentially what comes down to fart
songs which i very much appreciate and i
also want to say thanks to some people
who just signed up on my website
hector apodaca signed up on my website
michelle chase signed up brian hark
signed up and linda sturgis
signed up which puts us at 34
right out of the gate and of course the
most
important membership benefit is you get
the daily award-winning bonus show now
it's true the awards are all awards we
give out
like we gave out an award for the best
bonus show
and we won so i mean you know take with
a grain of salt that th that the bonus
show has won awards
but it has won awards they're just you
know awards we
establish and awards for which were the
only contending show but in all
seriousness i actually i
showed some of these yesterday we are
getting some pretty sizable
membership dumps people dumping
memberships for financial reasons
this is alex who said it's unfortunate
but i have ended my membership because
i've been unemployed since march
it's it's a sad reality uh here's rachel
my name is rachel and i would like to
cancel my membership i'm having
financial difficulties and can't spare
the expense
so it's sad that it really is sad that
this is going on we're committed to
continue
uh continuing to produce the program and
do the streams and everything we're
doing
and we want to scale it up actually so
my
only request is if to you if i say a
dollar eighty a month
and you say a dollar eighty a month
sounds reasonable to me
do the do the thing go to
joinpackman.com that coupon code fresh
start
will save you 70 you don't have to take
the coupon code we're not means testing
it
if you want the coupon code do it the
coupon codes will likely become illegal
under a future administration because
they're just so
big we'll probably have to tamp down to
like 40
off when biden comes in because i don't
think he's gonna go for 70
off if you understand what i'm saying um
so that's the message
go ahead and grab yourselves uh one of
those memberships
and one other thank you damian leblanc
damien leblanc is new member number 35
today very very important okay a few
other super chats are coming in stuart
says i enjoy the content you do with
destiny
yeah i did a um i did a show the other
day with destiny and it was it was
pretty powerful i'm not going to lie
chaka seki says gaseous giuliani
a aka nosferatu
now with covid he's basically spreading
viral farticles at hearings across the
country
america's mayor yes well said
very much so um jen
says i had to explain my three-year-old
to my three-year-old
that was trump saying dumps and he said
i think trump is broken
yeah very very well said very well said
um what do you think will be the
consequences of the cult following trump
has half the country is going to blame
biden for the weather when it's raining
yeah you know on on january 21st
how many people do you how many of you
believe that on january 21st at least
one of oan newsmax or fox news will be
blaming biden for the number of people
that died of the virus on january 20th
do you guys think we will see that on at
least one of those three channels
a bunch of people saying yes a few
people saying no okay
i think it's very plausible that during
the first week of biden's presidency
the failed response to the virus by the
united states
will be solely blamed on joe biden i
think there is no doubt
whatsoever gorko gekko
is advocating for karen 2020. that's
exciting yeah that's an idea
a big thank you to john adun
bro broski is that i'm guessing it's a
northern european name
it can't possibly be broski but it seems
funnier to imagine that that is the name
uh it might not even be john it might be
yan anyway i appreciate
that's a beautiful new membership chase
mcdonald has also signed up
so is david krieger and james
prendergast
which puts us at 39 very very strong
number
um oh the other thing is yeah i'm
preparing this for tomorrow
um but i guess i will i will mention it
joe biden
has uh spoken with dr anthony fauci
and has asked him yeah guys we talked
about giuliani at the start of the
stream
um fauci has been asked number one to
stay on at nih number two to become joe
biden's chief medical advisor and joe
biden
asked fauci about a
a hundred day please wear a mask sort of
thing and fauci said he thinks it's a
good idea now you're going to hear from
all sorts of right wingers
that the authoritarian joe biden is
going to make everybody wear a mask now
first and foremost joe biden can't make
everybody wear a mask
you just can't do it legally he can't do
it what joe biden is going to do
is to do probably a natural national
address and say
please wear a mask what's more
authoritarian than saying please
and he's going to call uh governors and
say
please encourage your citiz your
residents to wear a mask
that's not authoritarian authoritarian
is sending in the military when there's
legal protests trump did it
authoritarian is continuing to claim you
won an election
and will take the election even when you
lost that's trump
authoritarian is attacking the press and
saying they're the enemy of the people
joe biden saying pretty please wear a
mask
to save people that's not authoritarian
so i'm just
pre-warning you guys uh about what
you're
what you're likely going to hear over
the next
you know few weeks uh what are kelly
loffler's chances for winning the
election is it low or high it's a listen
it's about 50 50. these races are all
statistically tied in the polling
what does that mean guys i when we look
at the polling and we see that it's
48.48 i'm gonna pause and let the chat
tell me what does it mean when we see
that
it means nothing exactly right everybody
knows it
it means absolutely and completely
nothing we are
standing by for a debate between
kelly loffler and uh
i say loffler oh here we go let's start
good evening and welcome i'm russ
spencer evening anchor for fox 5 in
atlanta and you're watching the atlanta
press club loudermilk young debate
series
we are broadcasting from the studio of
georgia public broadcasting in atlanta
and we welcome viewers from across the
state and the country
this is the runoff debate for u.s senate
to fill the seat currently held by
georgia senator kelly lefler
and let's meet the candidates now they
are in alphabetical order republican
candidate kelly lefler
she was appointed to the u.s senate in
january of 2020
to replace retiring georgia senator
johnny isakson she is also part owner of
atlanta's wnba
team the atlanta dream there you go the
democrat candidate rafael warnock is the
senior pastor at everything
democratic ebenezer of course the church
where martin luther king jr was pastor
let's meet our panel now greg blue
democrat candidate is almost a slur at
this point like they use that as an
attack
and lisa ram is host and senior producer
of npr's morning edition on wabe radio
in atlanta
now let's get started the topics were
not shared with the candidates in
advance
the debate will be divided into three
rounds and in each round candidates will
have 60 seconds to answer questions and
30 seconds for a rebuttal
and as moderator i will determine when a
rebuttal is appropriate
in the first round candidates will be
asked two questions each and greg you
get the first question to senator lefler
senator lefler thanks for joining us
president trump opened his election
rally
last night by falsely claiming he won
georgia
according to certified state election
results he lost the state by about 12
000 votes
do you stand by his narrative that the
election was rigged and you support his
demand that governor kemp to call a
special session to seek to overturn
those results nasty
well first i want to thank the atlanta
press club for hosting this important
debate
and look it's vitally important that
georgians trust
our election process oh the president
has every right to every legal recourse
and that's what's taking place oh my god
for investigations and now there's 250
investigations open
here in georgia but the president was
also clear
that georgians need to come out and vote
for corrections you
and myself because of what's at stake in
this election oh my god you know chuck
schumer said
now we take georgia then we change
america
we all know what that change would be
they've been very clear they want to
raise
taxes on hard-working georgians they
want to defund the police
they want to open our borders they want
to implement the green new deal
i'm fighting for every single georgia
the question was the trump american
dream
that i was blessed to live senator do
you believe the the election was rigged
look greg it's very clear that there
were issues in this election there are
250 investigations
open including an investigation into one
of my opponents organizations
you know for voter fraud and oh my god
sure that georgians trust this process
because of what's at stake
in this election you know that the
promise that chuck schumer made was to
fundamentally
change america and i'm making sure that
we don't go down the road of socialism
socialism who's association to ask a
question of reverend warnock
dr warnock good evening good evening as
a pastor
there are those who are a little
uncomfortable with someone switching
from the pulpit to the senate floor in
washington
if elected how will you navigate the u.s
constitution's edict separating church
and state thank you so very much
it's wonderful to be here and i want to
thank everybody who tuned in
tonight i also became aware that
senator lefler lost a member of her
staff and i want to
extend my condolences to her and also to
the family of
of that young man uh listen my my whole
life
has been about service uh it is uh
why i entered into the ministry and uh i
am
running for the united states senate as
a continuation of that life project
uh the thing about me running for the
senate is that this gives me an
opportunity to work on the issues i've
been working on for years i've been
fighting for access to affordable health
care i've been fighting for voting
rights
i've been fighting for essential workers
ordinary people because i know what it's
like to be an ordinary person i grew up
in public housing the first college
graduate leftler did my family of 12.
i'm number 11. and if it were not for
pell grants low-interest student loans i
wouldn't be here
i know the importance of good federal
policy but that's not an answer to this
question for fighting families but
what does that transfer on affordable
housing and health care as you just
mentioned
well we gotta make sure that we center
ordinary people in all of the policy
that we do
uh you know i i grew up with a father
and a mother who
instilled in me great i i just want to i
wish he would have just said
uh as we have a secular society and we
have separation of church and state and
my personal beliefs
that are religious like anybody else's
won't change but they will not be part
of how i govern because we have
separation of church and state that's
the answer that's the right that should
be the right answer the wealthiest
member of congress only in america is
that possible
and i am fighting to make sure that kids
like me
whether they are growing up in public
housing down in savannah georgia or
rural disaffected communities in new
orleans that hurt them in georgia that's
a fair question
that's a fair question american dream
that i believe so much in
and i'm concerned that washington uh is
not focused on ordinary people
you can't tell the difference between
washington back rooms and corporate
boardrooms
my opponent represents uh the worst of
that kind of problem and that's why i'm
grateful for this opportunity
i'd like to respond please do thank you
i was born and raised on a farm i grew
up working in the fields i waitressed my
way through school and i was the first
in my family to graduate from college i
worked hard to live the american dream
and became a job creator right here in
georgia
but this type of rhetoric is a
distraction from the issues at hand
the democrats want to fundamentally
change america and the agent of change
is my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock
someone that has attacked police from
the pulpit someone that has attacked our
military someone that has agreed to
raise taxes on hard-working georgians
as much as two thousand dollars per
family off the bats
that's not what georgians need to get
through this pandemic and get our
economy going i'm fighting for the
american dream
every day how is that even an answer and
you're going to have an opportunity to
respond to those things because i know
greg is going to get to them it's his
turn to ask you a question yeah i
have a question on that same topic
you've been attacked for comments you've
made from the pulpit
about law enforcement and the military
foreign policy among others
you've also said they're taken out of
context but you made these remarks in a
public forum
why should georgians take them at face
value
look it's clear to me that my opponent
is going to work really hard spending
millions of dollars of her own money
trying to push a narrative about me
because she's clearly decided
that she does not have a case to be made
for why she should stay in that seat
i have worked my whole life to pull
people together
i've been working on criminal justice
reform i've worked alongside
law enforcement officers nobody's
answering any questions
so we care i don't know i actually
brought together
the law enforcement officers here in
this city the chief of police
the black black lives matter activists
the sitting attorney general
families parents all in my church
focused on working on these issues that
we've seen emerge
time and time again and we need somebody
who knows how to bring people together
rather than using these issues as a
political
point to be made these issues are tragic
and our law enforcement officers
lay it on the line every day they have
an ally with me
i just think that you can affirm what
law enforcement officers do
and hold them accountable senator left
for 30 seconds
you know my opponent radical liberal
raphael warnock
has called police officers gangsters
thugs
bullies and a threat to our children
when i gave him the chance to apologize
in our first debate he declined
he's also said that you can't serve god
and the military
he's used the bible to justify these
types of attacks
and make other divisive statements what
we need is someone who can bring
together
that can help us get through this
pandemic and rebuild our economy
across this country and right here in
georgia that's what i'm fighting for the
georgia audience she's probably
smart to do that sure i'd love to
respond listen
this is why i think folks have turned
off from politics
very often because people will turn
anything
into a kind of cynical political
argument
i was preaching that day from a very
familiar math
matthew text that says you can't serve
god
and mammon it was a sermon about
a moral foundation for everything that
we do and that when you have everything
in order
that actually makes you a better soldier
it also makes you a better senator
and had kelly lefler listen to the
sermon rather than trying to make a
cheap political point
she would not have used her advantage as
a u.s senator to
make millions on a pandemic while
playing it down to the people
she was nice okay that's good now we're
working with it
oh go ahead please you know i'm a
christian i'm a person of deep faith
right i don't need a lecture from
someone who has used the bible
to not only actually attacking our
military
that's not in matthew 6 24. it doesn't
say
you can't serve the military in god but
he's also used the bible to justify
abortion i cannot stand by and let
georgians know not know who my opponent
is how radical his views are and how he
would fundamentally change our country
he's out of step with george's values
abortion's legal so he really wouldn't
change anything to ask questions of each
other lisa has one last question
uh here for senator lefler senator
lefler good evening state
election official gabriel sterling
proclaimed this has to stop
he was referring to threats again thanks
for the raid benjamin feingold and the
secretary of state who received death
threats
sterling warned that false claims of
widespread election fraud could lead to
violence
he said somebody's going to get killed
right at his urging
you responded by denouncing the violence
but some didn't think that was enough
so tell us tonight what is your message
to those who have threatened officials
and have you made an effort to help
lower the temperature on the behalf of
the
republican party well absolutely as
someone who has been
the subject of threats of violence i
absolutely denounce it
but you know here's what's at stake the
future of our country
hangs on this state and announces the
threats against her
we have built an organization within our
campaign to make sure
that georgians trust this process and
president trump
has encouraged georgians to get out and
vote because the future of the country
is at stake on january 5th we need folks
to trust the process
because that's what makes our democracy
possible right here we've got to get to
the bottom
of these investigations that have
started too late there's 250
investigations
including into rafael warnock's voter
registration organization for the second
time for trying to register voters
in new york that doesn't represent the
voice of georgia
i'm going to fight to make sure that we
hold officials accountable
for carrying out free fair trusted
elections that are
accurate she definitely has and
cultivates you about this election much
has been made at president trump's
refusal to concede but two years ago
stacey abrams refused to concede the
governor's race saying that there was
voter suppression
do you think there was voter suppression
two years ago and do you think
this election has been fair uh
listen uh voter suppression is something
that happens all across our country
it's happened here in the state of
georgia but stacy abrams did not
refuse to acknowledge the fact that her
opponent was the governor
here we are several weeks after the
election and kelly lefler continues to
cast
doubt on an american democratic
election it's time to put this behind us
and get focused on the concerns
of ordinary people the way i would
handle this is i would say listen
voter suppression is something
republicans do every election
and it means closing polling places
purging voter rolls etc
they did it to stacey abrams and they
did it to joe biden the
difference is biden still got enough
votes to win that's how i would handle
this question
all the central workers and his central
wage i want to go
to the united states senate to stand up
for ordinary people
uh and when uh politicians aren't
satisfied with the voters
they try to pick their voters and that's
what's going on right now
may i respond please radical liberal
rafael warnock has partnered with stacy
abrams voter suppression conspiracies
when in fact we have
record turnout in our state year after
year
and you know it's unfortunate that the
focus is on a debate about who won the
election when this process is still
playing out and president trump has
every right to every
legal recourse but we also have to make
sure that georgia's know that we have a
process
that works that their vote is counted
and that no illegal votes are counted
and that's what i'm going to continue to
fight for to make sure that georgians
know
everything is at stake in this election
the future of our country
not just the radical ideas of the left
but the radical candidates
who would defund the police who would
stand by and attack our military and
then withdraw funds that would support
chuck schumer's uh defunding of our
military by 25 percent
we need that and i'm going to continue
to make sure that we come back from this
his radical positions are that he's in
favor of
uh abortion being legal which it already
is and he wants the green new deal
we want to get to the point where you
can ask each other questions that does
conclude the first portion of this
debate for people just tuning in
you are watching the runoff debate for
one of georgia's two u.s senate seats we
move now to the second round
where the candidates will ask each other
a question should be ready to have 30
seconds to ask a question
30 seconds to respond to their
opponent's answer reverend warner will
she say radical first question in her
question or
answer thank you so much uh senator
lefler when you
received the private briefing
regarding the coronavirus pandemic you
dumped
millions of dollars of stock in order to
protect your own investments and then
weeks later
when there came an opportunity to give
ordinary georgians
an extra six hundred dollars of relief
you said you saw no need and called it
counterproductive why do you think it's
counterproductive to help
ordinary georgians in the middle of a
pandemic
well thank you for that question because
i've been completely exonerated
those are lies perpetrated by the
left-wing media and democrats
to distract from their radical agenda
since i got to the senate i've worked
hard to deliver relief to georgians
during this pandemic and i'm continuing
to do that
but look what democrats have done they
have stood for
stonewalling relief that i voted for
twice in the senate
to deliver relief to families to farmers
to schools and hospitals
they're playing politics that's what
they're using their lies to cover up the
fact that they don't have a positive
agenda to lift georgians up
they want to defund the police raise
your taxes implement the green new deal
that would crush you better question
would be
why specifically did you dump all that
stock on that date
economy going again that we can drive
forward
after this pandemic and i've been
working side by side for my colleagues
to make sure
that we get that done and we have
delivered results 47 billion dollars
that i brought here to georgia save 1.5
million jobs at small businesses
reverend you have 30 seconds to respond
if you'd like listen
i do not want to defund the police and
kelly lefler knows it
but she keeps saying this because she
wants to distract from her own record
uh the truth of the matter is where it
left up to her
georgians would not have received the
600 of expanded unemployment insurance
and they haven't seen any relief in
months and she hasn't done
anything she's done nothing to provide
relief for ordinary people
the folks i'm seeing all across this
state who are in pain in the middle of
this pandemic
senator left your turn to ask a question
of reverend warnock
reverend warnock in your writings and
your teachings
you've repeatedly praised marxism and
the redistribution of
income can you here and now for all
georgians
renounce socialism and marxism
listen uh i believe in our free
enterprise system
and my dad was a small business owner
so he's not a socialist you know what i
was doing i i was
leading my church to build a community
center where among other things we had a
financial literacy center
that taught people how to repair their
credit create a 700 credit score commute
now how to create a business how to buy
a home
how to participate in our free
enterprise system
kelly lefla on the other hand was
teaching the big banks
how to hide their investments offshore
in the cayman islands
this is how she spent her career before
she went to the senate
this is what she's been focused on now
that she's in the senate
she was only there three weeks i'm not
sure she was fully unpacked when she
started dumping millions of dollars of
stock
trying to protect herself and uh
she purchased that seat yeah it's done
well for her to quit
the issue is that the people who sold it
to her don't own it and the people of
georgia coming back to get their seat
senator you have 30 seconds well
predictably you've just heard
more lies from radical liberal raphael
warnock who wants to distract from his
own words
police officers gangsters thugs bullies
and a threat to our children
saying that you can't serve god in the
military for his
attacks on israel you know what i'm
focused on
is making sure that we continue to
deliver relief i've already delivered
relief
for 174 thousand small businesses seven
billion dollars for hospitals
and when the government didn't move
quickly enough i purchased ppe
out of my own funds drove it to
hospitals i donated to hospitals and i
donate my salary to charities across
georgia i'm here working for georgia
reverend warnock your turn to ask a
second question of the senator
yeah my my question is actually pretty
simple
yes or no senator lefler did donald
trump
lose a recent presidential election
you know president trump has every right
to use
every course available in our own state
we've seen
time and again that we have
investigations that need to be completed
in fact we've run two audits and those
audits discovered
thousands of ballots across several
counties here in georgia that were not
counted
i've called for a signature audit we
need to hold
folks accountable involved in these
investigations to make sure that they
move more quickly because everything's
at stake on january 5th
for the future of our country if the
democrats win
they will defund the police they'll keep
asking the same questions
down they want more lockdowns senate
democrats don't want it
in the middle of a pandemic and they'll
continue to
keep the borders open and support
taxpayer funding
for illegal immigrant health care and
they'll defund our military by 25
percent
my opponent radical liberal rafael
warnock would be a rubber stamp
for chuck schumer because he's bought
and paid for by tens of millions of
dollars
consumer would get whatever he wants
liberal money from chuck schumer
reverend warnock 30 seconds you know
i've been moving all across this state
especially going to rural areas and when
i go to these small
towns they're surprised that i'm there
i'm surprised
that they're surprised they haven't seen
a u.s senator should ask the same
question again
they're wondering why their hospitals
are closing
why kelly leflar doesn't think it's a
good idea
to make sure that they have health care
in the middle of a pandemic we refuse to
expand medicaid in the state
nine of our hospitals are closing have
closed
and they're wondering who in washington
is looking out for them
senator leffler you get the final
question i would like to see him ask it
again reverend warnock
you were arrested for obstructing police
and the arrests
in in the child abuse investigation
can you tell me the nature of this child
abuse what
why were the police called what was your
knowledge or involvement
in this incident sure hear the facts and
kelly lefler actually knows them
i was working and trying to make sure
that
young people who were being questioned
by law enforcement
had the benefit of counsel a lawyer
or a parent and the law enforcement
officers
actually later thanked me for my
cooperation
and for helping them she knows this but
the question is why is she doing this
it is because she has made a calculation
that after being in the senate for 10
months
she does not have a case to be made for
why the people of georgia
should keep her there her calculation
may be right focused on the same things
she's focused on
her whole life the mud slinging may work
herself during the recession she was
helping billionaires like her hide their
money in the cayman islands
she dumped millions of dollars of stock
laid it down and then she when she could
help ordinary people
she didn't do it and the people of
georgia haven't seen relief
for months and so she's spending her
millions of dollars focused on me
because she has no case to make for
herself i think that's sad but there's
no reason
for her to keep a senate seat you have a
rebuttal
you've just heard radical liberal
raphael warnock lie
again and not answer a question an
important question that
georgians deserve to have the answer he
actually did answer unfortunately this
is consistent with his track record of
disrespecting law enforcement
anyone in georgia can read the police
report as to what happened in this child
abuse investigation at his church camp
you know georgians deserve answers but
they also deserve someone who respects
our men and women of law enforcement you
know he did call police officers
gangsters and thugs
he said that we should empty the prisons
and in cash bail he won't keep our
community
safe that's what i'm fighting for
senator thank you
that does conclude our second round
again if you're just joining us this is
the runoff debate between candidates
for the u.s senate seat to fill the
georgia seat the sad thing is this is
probably a good strategy
now to the panel to ask questions until
we run out of time as moderator actually
i'm going to take the privilege of
asking a question to the two of you to
start this round
uh reverend i'll begin with you i'm
interested in the number
that you're comfortable with when it
comes to coronavirus relief
uh senate majority leader mcconnell
seems to favor something like 500
billion the moderates are talking about
908 two months ago the white house
suggested
1.8 trillion and the democrats wanted
more how much is
required by this moment well well the
problem is for months we haven't seen
any
relief and we can talk about the numbers
that would be an important part of the
conversation
but when we saw relief we saw the
shake shacks of the world and roofs
chris and
the la lakers at the front of the line
and small businesses at the back of the
line
our front line workers our teachers our
police officers
our health professionals need ppe
our workers need relief and we need to
begin
even now i think thinking beyond how we
survive this pandemic and begin to think
about how we survive
on the other end of the pandemic while
we're providing relief
i think it's time for us to start
thinking about an infrastructure program
here in this country that will repair
our roads and our bridges
begin to build green energy and green
energy energy jobs
provide jobs with a livable wage and
position our economy
again i think he could start you could
not give a number but say the number is
going to be higher the longer it takes
us to do it you know
i i something like that might have been
good make sure that whatever we do
workers are at the center of that relief
all right
senator leffler you're in a position to
vote on this very soon
perhaps janet yellen has said the
country can afford to borrow this money
now
to get people through this crisis until
we're all vaccinated really borrow if we
don't spend it now it's going to cost us
more
in terms of job destruction do you agree
with that and what would your number be
what could you live with
well i was pleased to support all the
relief packages this spring when we were
addressing this virus
over three trillion dollars of relief to
americans
47 billion that i helped bring right
here to georgia including seven billion
four hospitals uh 174 000 small
businesses
that i brought 15 billion dollars in ppp
funds to save 1.5 million
jobs and in fact i voted twice on the
senate floor in recent months
to support a package that democrats have
blocked that nancy pelosi has now
confirmed
that it was a playing politics with
americans lives and livelihoods she's
held up
targeted relief that would have gone to
hospitals
to schools to families to small
businesses
that's what i've been fighting for
that's what the democrats are holding up
and my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock neither will
stand for chuck schumer and nancy pelosi
as they try to use this pandemic
to put them what's funny is a real
radical would be like nancy and chuck
are way too moderate
to fundamentally change america and i'm
not going to stand by and let that
happen i'm going to make sure that we
serve our families and our small
businesses right here in georgia
thank you lisa it's your turn to ask a
question senator leffler
you have called yourself the most
conservative candidate in the race
you're also the richest u.s senator with
an estimated net worth of more than a
half billion dollars
how will you use your wealth and your
privilege to improve the life of the
average georgian
the one who makes minimum wage and a lot
of people specifically minorities who
feel you have not made an attempt to
meet them
where they are well first of all
i have been blessed to live the american
dream and that's what i'm fighting for
every single day in washington what
because i was born and raised on a farm
i grew up working in the fields i
started filling out a time card when i
was 11.
i waitressed my way through high school
and college and i was the first in my
family to graduate from college
i know what it means to live paycheck to
paycheck i've done it
and i also know i'm blessed to live the
american dream and that's why i'm
fighting to protect it
that's why conservative values matter to
uphold the constitution
our freedoms are our understanding it
wasn't about country
the religious freedom uh the right to
life the second amendment
and that's what helps create opportunity
for all georgians to live freely
but my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock
is a socialist he supports policies that
would grow our government
bankruptcy not running as one families
with high taxes the cost of the green
new deal on every georgian family would
be seventy five thousand dollar
dollars and taxes would go up two
thousand dollars per family
that's why i'm focused on helping every
single georgian
succeed she gave that answer already out
to minority communities to hear their
issues and what they're thinking and
what they're feeling
absolutely i have built my career
based on bringing folks together to lift
everyone up
examples that's what i've done from day
one in fact i just
introduced my prosperity plan that would
bring
much needed capital access to capital
sounds like a church fundraiser small
businesses in minority communities
because our country has failed in that
area that's one way we can help we can
also make sure that we protect
school choice the democrats would
overturn
school choice trapping children uh
their destiny for education within their
zip code yes
i'm fighting to make sure that destiny
school choice and support
kids to live their dream to have that
education
but i'm also making sure we keep taxes
low the taxes
the jobs uh act that rafael warnock
would overturn
would raise taxes on single moms making
39 000
with two kids their taxes would go up 20
percent
that's not a way to help hard-working
families here in georgia succeed
greg bluestein your turn to ask a
question yeah and this next question is
for both candidates
we'll start with reverend do you plan to
accept a chronovirus vaccine when public
health experts
declare to be safe and if so how do you
plan to persuade the public to take it
absolutely when when our health
professionals tell us that we have a vet
he's not going to decline the vaccine or
not answer right
and as effective and safe i will take it
i will encourage the folks who listen to
me people who are in my church
and in the community to take it but also
i will
try to work hard as a senator to make
sure that communities that are so often
marginalized
don't find themselves at the back of the
line again that they have access
to the vaccine so often they find
themselves at the back of the line
and i've spent my life standing up
fighting for ordinary people kelly
lefler is trying to
misrepresent me because she knows that
she has spent
the first 10 months all 10 months of her
tenure
thinking about herself she's the
unelected senator of georgia she was
appointed
the people of georgia have been
disappointed and they're looking for
somebody who'll stand up for ordinary
people
i've spent my life doing that as a
citizen and i'll do it as a u.s senator
you have 30 seconds to respond to that
before greg asks this question of you
you know i have spent every single day
working for georgians i'm a hundred
percent about georgia that was my
calling to public service
i was blessed to live by the way guys do
not drink every time she says radical
liberal because you will be
soused in this race that knows how to
help georgians i've created jobs
he's never created a job in his life but
yet he's advocated for high taxes that
would crush small businesses
and families seeking that opportunity he
would take away school choice
for kids who want to have that leg up
and he would play politics just as nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer have done
holding up relief for political reasons
and i think that's completely wrong
greg you had a reminder of the question
do you plan to accept the corner virus
vaccine if public health experts say
it's safe and
if so how do you intend to persuade the
public to take it
absolutely i was with vice president
pence on friday at the cdc
i could not be more proud of what we've
done this year to deliver relief
but also get cures vaccines and
therapies that are effective
and so i'm going to encourage my fellow
georgians
to stay safe to get that vaccine and we
have a great plan to prioritize
those communities who need it most and
we will make sure that that's carried
out
but my opponent will continue to play
politics with the pandemic
telling lies and trying to achieve
political objectives
i would try to radically change our
country at a moment of a pandemic
i'm going to continue to fight for every
single georgian to have the freedoms and
the opportunities
that they deserve why did he tell about
the big government that would
have government mandated health care
that would provide free health care for
illegal immigrants that would raise
their taxes to
pay for government health care and that
would bankrupt medicare
i'm making sure that georgians have the
resources they need while we keep our
taxes and our government
low and small lisa it's your turn to ask
a question
dr warnock katina stravalakis is an
atlanta business owner who had to close
her doors because
she was unable to pay thousands in back
rent due to the pandemic
president-elect joe biden considers it a
top priority to get a generous stimulus
package through congress
and you said you support that i love
this woman's voice if you were to speak
to katina what would you insure her that
you would do
in washington to help her and other
business owners get the help that they
need
well my dad was a small business owner
and so i
understand the struggle that small
business owners have
and i spent time in my church creating a
financial literacy center
uh that helps people to get started and
so
i think a good sign of what someone will
do
in office is what they were doing before
they ever went into office
and i've spent my whole career standing
up for ordinary people
trying to in fact we had a job center in
my church
contrary to what senator lefler is
trying to suggest
and i have stood up for
ordinary workers time and time again you
know during this pandemic we call people
essential workers we ought to pay them
an essential wage
and we ought to provide small business
owners like her
the assistance and the support that they
need
kelly leffler's out of touch she's
thinking about people who are like her
and i'm okay with the fact that she
wants to make money
i just think you shouldn't use the
people's seat
to enrich yourself you ought to use the
people seat
to represent the people i'd like to
respond please do
look these are more lies from radical
liberal raphael warnock there it is one
that has
invited fidel castro a murderous
dictator into his own church someone
that has celebrated
anti-american anti-semite jeremiah
wright
you know he has also said that police
officers are gangsters and thugs and
refuse to apologize for it he said that
you can't serve god and the military
he has actually made sure that we know
who he is
in his own words those aren't my words
i'm working hard to serve georgians i've
served thousands of georgia
he should do that thing that chris
christie did to marco rubio during the
debate
he should go she's she's repeating the
same thing
she's repeated the same lines seven
eight times now is
are you guys noticing that no matter
what the question is she repeats the
same line again and again
endemic and it's too bad that she's
engaged in the politics of distraction
and division i never met him i never
invited him he has nothing to do with me
if you want to know who informs me and
my
sense of how we engage as people
in the economic system you need to look
no further
than matthew 25 i'm a matthew 25
christian that's what i am
i i was hungry and you fed me i was
thirsty and you gave me something to
drink
i was sick and you visited me love your
neighbor
and for me that means you don't get rid
of your neighbor's health care
particularly in the middle of a pandemic
greg may i respond go ahead
look i'm not going to be lectured by
someone that uses the bible to justify
abortion do we attack our men and women
the military
you know what's happening someone who
will not own up to their own record
of division he has called on americans
to repent for their worship of whiteness
that's divisive that's hurtful he
celebrated jeremiah wright anti-semite
he's
actually called israel an apartheid
state
that is wrong for america and i'm going
to continue to make sure georgians
understand
that that is him in his own words
reverend please respond to the abortion
issue in particular
well listen i i have a profound
reverence for life and an abiding
respect for choice the question is whose
decision is it and i happen to think
that
a patient's room is too small a place
for a woman her doctor and the u.s
government i think that's too many
people in the room
uh remember also that abortion is legal
and
unless that changes what does he have to
do with that as a senator
rates of infant mortality and maternal
mortality in our country
when compared to other developed nations
that's something the government could
work on
and i've been working on it my entire
career greg bluestein
senator president trump has attacked
your closest political ally governor
kemp
as hapless he said he was ashamed to
support him he even invited
uh one of your former rivals to run
against him in 2022.
was the president wrong to say that
about the governor and are you concerned
his comments could
alienate some republicans in georgia
ahead of the runoffs
well the president has the right to
pursue every legal recourse to make sure
that this was a free
and fair election written on the wall
and we know what about attacking
thousands of votes that were initially
uncounted and i've called for a
signature audit
and the buck stops with the secretary of
state he has to run an election
that georgians trust because
everything's at stake on january 5th the
future of the country
we can take the path of supporting the
american dream of standing the economy
back up and getting through this virus
together
or we can take the path of socialism
that radical liberal rafael warnock
wants to bring to our country
increasing our taxes taking away the
private insurance that you get at your
jobs and replacing it with
government-run health care
you know turning your doctor's office
into the dmv
he would open our borders grant amnesty
give free health care to illegal
immigrants
none of that will help us solve this
pandemic and get the economy back on its
feet notice it's the same talking points
trump had about biden none of them true
of course
by someone that has not done anything
for americans during this pandemic
but was the president wrong when he
called those governors those remarks
look the president i appreciate the
president's support of me and i
supre appreciate the governor's support
of me they both understand what's at
stake in this election
that's why they're encouraging georgians
to get out and vote for david perdue
and myself because we're fighting for
georgians every single day we're using
our private sector experience to make
sure that georgians get back to work
and school and church while the
democrats play politics
hold up relief and try to keep our
country locked down
that's just wrong i'd say they should
hire to do the voice for siri but it
wouldn't sound human enough
again president trump criticized your
governor
governor brian kemp governor kemp
appointed you to the senate
you've you've criticized the election
process as well so tonight can you tell
us
where your loyalty lies as you vie to
represent the state of
georgia is it with governor kemp or
president trump
lisa my loyalties are with georgia i had
a calling to public service to serve the
people of georgia
look i have lived the american dream i
want to make sure every georgian can do
that
uh from going from working on a farm
from waitressing
uh being the first in my family to
graduate from it's stuck on repeat
um you know free free enterprise is the
way to lift everyone up
so much not high taxes not big
government warnock just said
not the chaos of defunding the police
that the left wants not the lockdowns
i'm making sure that georgians know
what's at stake on january 5th
our way of life right here in georgia
will radically change
as promised by chuck schumer now we take
georgia
then we change america that's my number
one focus
making sure that georgians know what's
at stake
i have served georgians every single day
it's been my honor and i'm going to
continue to do that she's stuck on a
loop if everything is at stake on
january 5th that would presume
that president trump has lost is that
what you're saying
you know what's at stake is the senate
majority this will determine
who brings bills to the senate
everything and under
uh the republican senate we've been able
to deliver delivery
we won't say trump laws of relief to
hard-working americans
hard hit by this pandemic to the front
line workers to hospitals
to schools we have to continue to make
sure that we open up our economy
the democrats want to keep this locked
down they want to radically change our
country
and their agent of change is radical
liberal raphael warnock
someone that has said to reimagine
police that is endorsed
by organizations is to defund the police
we know the direction the country would
take and we're going to continue to make
sure
that georgians understand that our very
way of life here in georgia
and across the country is under attack
by the witchy software
labor the point but all those things
that you're warning about would not be
happening presumably with president
trump as president so
it almost sounds as though you're
conceding that that part of it has been
settled
and now it's important for the
republicans to to keep the majority in
the senate
to uh to have a divided government
well i saw firsthand that the senate is
the shock absorber in this country and i
saw that firsthand
i saw the the russia hoax does not
distracted us from addressing this virus
the democrats have
played nothing but politics since day
one they've never
accepted that president trump was
president they were distracted from
serving americans
they were distracted during the pandemic
and now they've i think they didn't
install all the windows updates before
the debate and now she's stuck in a loop
big government on the back of
hard-working georgians
that's why i'm fighting to make sure
that the republican majority is retained
in the senate
because we are the shock absorber for
common sense policies
that bring americans together that lift
everyone up that provides for
great educational choices for kids that
stops the
radical agenda of the abortion on demand
that democrats want
that attacks our second amendment rights
they want to take away
our guns they want to tax essentially
has
four lines for the whole debate america
and radical liberal rafael warnock is
their agent of change
greg bluestein time for your question
yeah reverend warnock if democrats do
win control of the u.s senate
if you can do this for me for tomorrow's
show
uh a compilation of her saying radical
leftist raphael warnock
and then another one of the repeats
brother you understand i would use those
tomorrow if someone can put that
together for me that kelly lefla
actually voted
to defund the police she voted against
the cops program she was one of only 10
united states senators who did i don't
think we should defund the police
but we certainly do need criminal
justice reform we need to make sure that
we have an independent review process
when civilians die at the hands of
police we need to make sure
that police and officers and departments
that have a pattern of misconduct
are held accountable we can do that and
celebrate
police at the same time
and as i move all across the state greg
people aren't asking me
about the courts and whether we should
expand the courts i know that's an
interesting question for people inside
the beltway to discuss
but they're wondering when in the world
are they going to get some covet 19
relief
they haven't gotten any from kelly
leffler in months
and when she had a chance to stand up
for ordinary people
she thought six hundred dollars was too
much meanwhile she was
busy dumping millions of dollars of
stock huge dumps profiting from a
pandemic
who does that but it will impact people
on the ground
so i am wondering if you can answer the
question do you support
expanding the supreme court i'm really
not focused on it
um and i think that too often
the politics in washington has been
about the politicians
i'm a pastor and so when i think about
these issues
i think about the people that i've had
to stand with
in the critical care units while their
loved one was dying or
between life and death and not only are
they concerned about the sickness
they're wondering how in the world
they're going to pay for it
if kelly lefler has her weight 1.8
million georgians with pre-existing
conditions that means people with
hypertension
people with diabetes folks who've had a
stroke cancer
people who are recovering from covet
would not be able to
get health care did she freeze i think
that's morally wrong
and it's my faith that actually informs
that she can't explain
why she wants to take away people's
health care she knows that that junk
health care plan that she rolled out
has a loophole in it big enough to drive
a mech truck through
she can't explain that and so she's
trying to misrepresent my record
but the people of georgia understand uh
they they understand the truth
senator 30 seconds please look you've
just heard
radical liberal rafael warnock lie about
my record
i've never voted to defund the police in
fact i've
voted to support more funding that the
democrats of course
blocked but he also is distracting from
the fact
that he would pack the supreme court
that's outrageous
it wouldn't be updated justice ginsburg
herself said nine justices is the right
number
he would pack the court with radical
justices that would legislate from the
bench
to fundamentally override the
constitution and our laws in this
country
and georgians need to know that is wrong
legislating from the bench
would you like 30 seconds to respond
well i believe in the constitution
this is the greatest system on the
planet and
our country is the only country where my
story is even possible
i believe in our norms i believe in the
separation of powers
and i believe in the non-violent
unchaotic
transition of power kelly lefla ought to
stand with the people of georgia
the four greatest words ever spoken in
the democracy are the people have spoken
the people have spoken on the
presidential election and they're
waiting on
their senator to be focused on them
not the person in the white house lisa
ram
senator leffler given all the police
violence we've seen against
african-americans
consider this courtney owens of atlanta
is worried about her son her father and
her husband all african-americans she
fears for their lives daily
you've called the black lives matter
movement fascist
you've alienated members of your own
basketball team by talking about that
stance or taking that stance rather
is that still your view tonight after
seeing and hearing
how it hits home with so many people
personally and what conversation would
you sit down and have with courtney
owens
well the life of every african-american
is important and there is no place for
important in this country
racism is bad for organizations whose
number one goal
is to defund the police and we know that
that
hurts minority communities more than
anyone and we have to stand with our men
and women of law enforcement and i will
always do that
you know that's a distraction from the
fact that my opponent does not
stand with police officers by
organizations whose number one goal is
to defund the police he's called police
officers
gangsters thugs bullies here we go
threat to our children
he's called for our prisons to be opened
up and emptied out
he's called for the abolishment of the
cash bail system
look he doesn't care about safety and
security in any community
we've got to reboot to make sure that we
have the resources to keep our
communities safe
and our police department's well-funded
and well-trained you can tell she's
really passionate
senator thank you would you like to
respond to sure if particularly about
opening up the opening up the jails
well listen um first of all
uh the land of the free
is the mass incarceration capital of the
world we warehouse
25 of the world's prisoners and
people on both sides of the aisle know
that our current criminal justice system
needs reform and we saw that this summer
a multi-racial coalition of conscience
pouring out into american streets after
the tragic deaths of george floyd and
brionna taylor
and ahmad aubry and so many others and
what did kelly lefla do she used her
enormous privilege and power
as a united states senator to pick a
fight
with the black women on her team who
know what it's like to grow up in a
community where you have to have two
talks
with your children one with about the
birds and the bees
the birds and the bees in the other
about what happens if you're pulled over
by police officers
to acknowledge that is not to condemn
police officers in general
i've worked with police across the years
i've been invited to speak at their
memorial services
when they have lost love when they've
lost their lives
in the line of duty and she says she
is against racism and that racism has no
place
but she welcomed the support of a q anon
conspiracy theorist and she sat down
with a white supremacist for an
interview
true i i don't think she can explain
that imagine having to confirm you're
against racism give you a chance to
respond to that and then we'll have one
last question
and i claim to be against races well
that's
incredibly sad these comments that he's
made i mean first of all
there's not a racist bone in my body i
have worked to bring communities
together
my entire life but this is
really terrible coming from someone who
has
divided people continually he's called
on americans to repent
for their worship of whiteness he's
called israel an apartheid state
and said that we should end military
assistance he's
compared israelis defending themselves
against palestinians
he's compared them to birds of prey and
he celebrated jeremiah wright an
anti-american
anti-semite that's divisive greg
bluestein one last question
senator should members of congress be
barred from trading stocks
look what's at stake here in this
election
is the american dream that's what's
under attack
oh no for a lie that caught her off
guard media
lie conspired with the democrats by
this is an attack on every single
georgian who gets up
every day to work hard to provide a
better life
for their family who wants to live the
american dream
that is slippery from the real issues
not the conspiracies in this election
what's at stake is the future of our
country
our freedoms to live the american dream
to not be
taxed into bankruptcy to not have to go
onto government
health care government-run healthcare
they want to take away the health care
that 180 million americans are going to
come back to this question
that's why i've introduced a health care
plan to make it more affordable
not government-run health care that
would bankrupt those that rely on
medicare
and i'm going to continue to fight to
keep our country free
to keep our borders secure and make sure
that our communities are
safe and secure reverend you have an
opportunity to respond
well i mean the senator can't explain
why
the people of georgia should send her
back to the senate
and so she's continued to misrepresent
my record
she's lied not only on me but on jesus
i mean everybody's clear about what that
passage
is about in matthew you can't
serve two masters and she should have
listened to the lesson
maybe she wouldn't be so focused on
herself she'd be thinking about the
people
she's supposed to represent i intend
to center the concerns of the ordinary
people that i've been running
into all across this state particularly
in rural georgia
reverend thank you i'd like to respond
we're out of time i apologize but you're
going to have a chance for a closing
statement here in a moment that is all
the time we have for questions
wait but the candidates now have 60
seconds for a closing statement senator
you get to go first well thank you to
everyone who tuned in
to this important debate you can see
what's at stake there are two visions
for our country
mine the american dream my opponent
the ballot socialism 5th the american
dream
i was born and raised on a farm i grew
up working in the fields
i built my career i became a job creator
right here in georgia
and i have been blessed to live the
american dream but chuck schumer said it
best
now we take georgia then we change
america
they would increase our taxes open our
borders socialize our health care
and my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock is his agent of change
someone that has falsely used the bible
to attack our military
the bible never said that we serve that
you can't serve god and in the military
he's attacked our police officers
he wants to fundamentally change america
into a socialist country
well i'm not going to let that happen
i'm working hard for every single
georgian
i'm kelly leffler i'm asking for your
vote on january 5th
thank you and may god bless america
thank you senator reverend
your closing statement thank you so much
and thanks to everybody who tuned in
tonight i'm raphael warnock
uh i'm one of 12 children in my family
and i'm number 11.
the first college graduate listen these
are dark and difficult times
and against the thick fog of this
pandemic
and the economic turndown even during
this season of joy it's hard for people
to find joy i think about my dad
in a moment like this god bless his
memory he used to wake me up every
morning at dawn and said get ready get
dressed put shoes on
it was dawn and so it was
morning but it was still dark it's dark
right now
but morning is on the way
it's our job georgia to put our shoes on
and get ready because there are those
who are engaged in the politics of
division they have no vision
and so they engage in division tomorrow
is the last day to register
tell everybody you know to make a vote
plan because health care is on the
ballot
workers are on the ballot voting rights
is on the ballot
criminal justice reform is on the ballot
and if you give me the honor of
representing you in the u.s senate
we have to go thinking about georgia
every single day thank you very much
reverend and senator before we conclude
this debate everyone involved in
tonight's production
sends their condolences to the leftler
campaign and to the family of staff
member harrison diehl who was killed in
a car accident on
friday our thoughts are with the family
they're with you we're very very sorry
we'd like to remind voters that election
day is tuesday january 5th
absentee voting has already begun in
georgia and early voting in georgia
begins december 14th
thanks to the candidates and to the
panel for participating in this debate
well done
thanks to the atlanta press club and
georgia public broadcasting for
arranging this debate
i'm russ spencer with fox 5 in atlanta
thank you for joining us for the atlanta
press club loudermilk young
so whoa that was abrupt so when they go
to um
when they go to this question of should
members of the senate be banned from
selling from trading stocks
she obviously doesn't think that they
should right but there's a way that you
can handle that question without looking
like such a doofus which is to say
listen that's not something i've given a
lot of thought
to but if we as a senate determined that
that was in the best interests of the
country
i wouldn't stand in the way on principle
but i would examine it because
it's never going to happen right like
you you can answer that in a way where
you don't look like you're so
obviously trying to avoid the question
and it reinvigorates all these questions
about her stock trades like
you can just say i you know there's
there's a million ways you can answer
that because it's never going to happen
you're never going to be banned from
trading stocks because you're in the
senate
it's very very strange um okay
uh a very weird debate um
for sure and i guess she had about five
or six different
answers that she gave there's a real
question you know people saying she was
very unskilled she's unskilled
politically
she didn't win this race she was
appointed it's very important to
remember that so it's
completely conceivable that had she
never and she may win
on january 5th but she would partially
win because of the power of incumbency
the fact that she's been there for 10
months what will by then be 11 months
she's someone who never may have had a
shot if she actually had to run to begin
with and that's a completely reasonable
thing to say i'm so glad you joined me
for this debate
even if it was wacky if you're watching
on youtube
please remember to hit the subscribe
button on your your way out i'm not
asking you for any money
it's free you just hit subscribe and you
make it more likely that youtube will
recommend you a video of mine you won't
even be
forced to watch it in the future and if
you're watching over on
twitch i would also love it if you
follow
my channel before you head out really
appreciate you joining me we're back to
a full week of shows
tomorrow regular schedule and i will see
everybody then
and very soon